thank Christ
was just pressed guys we're meeting up
Jota guitars in the middle of a live
shot hey don't let you there come on you
yes we are we're doing a job and this is
the Senate Senate print synchronization
so come on
where would you like us to go okay
Thank You officer well given those
incidents we asked f on for his
assessment of police conduct in
Minneapolis tonight well I would say
they did their job today at least as
outlined by their superior slash
politicians governor of the state as
well as the municipal government here
remember they didn't show up the last
three days before today or nights just
yesterday we had a curfew installed here
too but there was no police had no
National Guard actually even close to be
able or willing to enforce this and this
has changed today conduct as you can see
in this scene where my cameraman max
Ferg and I had this encounter just a
little bit of context three police cars
had actually encircled another TV
production team we don't know from what
network and as we do in the field here
we then rush there and try to document
this not to interfere but document this
and as you saw nerves were a little bit
frazzled there I can somewhat understand
this because those those policemen are
under a lot of stress doing their job
but of course they should have let us
work and do our job but you know what
did you you're not I was or we were not
about to pick a fight tonight